bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia a propósito de las elecciones
presidenciales en irán de este 18 de
junio de 2021 que trazan un relevo
político de la influyente nación de
medio oriente haremos un compendio de
los presidentes que han liderado la
república islámica desde su fundación en
1979 cabe recordar que irán se fundó
como república islámica al término de la
revolución iraní de comienzos de 1979 un
estallido de la sociedad en contra de la
monarquía del último sha mohammad reza
pahlavi los iraníes
hastiados de la violenta represión del
monarca por medio de su temida policía
secreta shabak así como de la corrupción
su extravagancia su romance con
occidente y su indiferencia ante las
necesidades del pueblo detonaron una
revolución que lo derrocó y lo forzó a
exiliarse en eeuu mientras él chapab la
vi escapaba de irán el ayatolá jomeiní
regresaba del exilio en parís y se
proclamaba líder de la revolución y
líder supremo de irán
el 2 y 3 de diciembre de 1979 fue
aprobada mediante referendo la nueva
constitución de la república islámica de
irán que reemplazó a la antigua carta
magna- de 1906 de tal suerte el primer
presidente de iran elegido
democráticamente fue a borja sam vanessa
a dar hombre de confianza del ayatolá
jomeiní su período de cuatro años
comenzó el 4 de febrero de 1980 pero
ante el estallido de la guerra contra
irak en septiembre de ese mismo año fue
severamente criticado por su liderazgo
de las tropas iraníes su denominado
débil desempeño en la guerra fue el
argumento del parlamento para cesarlo
del poder el 22 de junio de 1981
entretanto el ayatolá jomeiní quedó a
cargo de las fuerzas armadas iraníes en
su lucha contra la invasión de irak y
paralelamente se declaró un consejo
presidencial provisional quien fungía
como primer ministro mohamad ali rajai
fue prontamente elegido como el segundo
presidente de la república islámica en
agosto de 1981 pero
duró 14 días en el cargo porque fue
asesinado en un atentado terrorista
perpetrado por facciones de los
mujahidines la inestabilidad política
que sufrió irán recién comenzaba a su
fase de república se ha quieto con la
llegada al poder de alí jamenéi en la
presidencia el 13 de octubre de 1981
antiguo activista revolucionario y
ferviente aliado del ayatolá jomeiní
este clérigo fue dos veces presidente de
iran desde el comienzo de la república
defendió ardientemente el concepto de un
gobierno religioso y fundamentalista
trabajó estrechamente con la guardia
revolucionaria en la desgastante guerra
contra irak que duró largos ocho años
dado que la salud del ayatolá jomeiní el
líder supremo de irán empeoró
considerablemente para finales de la
década de 1980 se comenzó a buscar su
sucesor con la modificación de la
constitución en 1989 y la muerte del
ayatolá jomeiní el 3 de junio del mismo
año ali jamenéi fue nombrado como el
próximo líder supremo
espiritual para la década de 1990 el
cuarto presidente de irán fue akbar
hashemí rafsanjaní en sus ocho años de
mandato privilegio en política interior
la liberalización económica por medio de
la privatización de empresas estatales
en política exterior
rafsanjaní tendió puentes diplomáticos
con sus países vecinos a tal punto que
fue invitado a arabia saudita en el
marco de la normalización de relaciones
tras años de enemistad pero comenzando
el nuevo milenio la declaración de
guerra en contra del terrorismo de eeuu
y la posterior invasión a irak de
occidente en el año 2003
desestabilizaron nuevamente la región de
medio oriente fueron los años en que
mohamad jatamí el quinto presidente
iraní estuvo al mando gobierno de 1997 a
2005 y fue considerado el primer
presidente reformista de irán en su
lucha por democratizar las leyes de
presidentes moderados y reformistas
los iraníes eligieron en el año 2005 a
un presidente conservador
pero sobre todo polémico en el campo
internacional mahmud amadineyad
amadineyad gobernó de 2005 a 2013 y fue
reconocido en el mundo por su desprecio
hacia israel sus aseveraciones contra la
existencia del estado israelí y su deseo
de obtener energía atómica mediante el
enriquecimiento de uranio le valieron a
iran un cerco de sus vecinos y múltiples
sanciones de eeuu sólo en 2013 con la
llegada al poder de hasan rojano el
séptimo y último presidente de iran la
atención entre la nación islámica y
occidente se calmó rohan y presidente
moderado y jamenéi líder supremo y ante
la crisis económica que vivía el país
abrieron el diálogo y firmaron con la
administración obama el acuerdo nuclear
de irán de 2015 de esta manera irán
logró que se levantaran las sanciones en
su contra a cambio de un desarrollo
nuclear vigilado y lejos de la
producción de la bomba atómica sin
embargo la partida de obama y la llegada
de trump a la casa blanca forzaron la
lectura de la
nuclear en 2018 y restituyeron las
sanciones para colmo la economía interna
no repuntó como lo había prometido roja
ni en 2019 los iraníes estallaron
socialmente en masivas protestas por la
costosa calidad de vida y la falta de
oportunidades para la clase trabajadora
ahora en 2021 y acabada la segunda
presidencia de rohan y el nuevo
presidente deberá enfrentarse entre
varios a dos retos evidentes revitalizar
la estancada economía de irán que
mantiene a su pueblo descontento y
afianzar con occidente el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 para librarse de las
temidas sanciones y calmar las tensiones
internacionales así llegamos al final
soy andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]